- I'm really sorry, guys.
We really screwed up.
A lot of you may have noticed
in some of the videos recently
how crappy the audio quality is.
That's because my camera
guy messed up on the audio.
I've been using the same
camera guy for a long time
and he's great and he really
cares deeply about the quality
of the videos and he takes
a lot of pride in his work,
and we didn't notice the day of,
so I film once a month usually
the first or second Thursday,
no, first or second
Wednesday of the month,
and that, we just recorded
and he didn't notice
that the audio wasn't picking up properly
and we just basically figured out
once we transferred all the files.
And I know a lot of you
guys are complaining,
a lot of you guys are
upset, and rightfully so.
The audio sounds like junk and
it's not our usual standard
and I appreciate the love,
I appreciate the support,
I appreciate you trying to
hold me to higher standards.
I sincerely do, so we
had options, you know.
It was either we keep it up as it is,
not film it again for our schedule
until the beginning of
next month and we decided,
you know what, the points are still good.
The points are still good.
I like the content.
The audio sucks, but the
points are still good.
I still want to give you guys value.
It's not what you're used
to and again I'm sorry,
but the content is still good,
and I hope you will bear with me,
have some patience as these
videos keep coming out
until probably the first week of August,
maybe the second week of August
just depending on the production schedule.
Yeah, and you know what, mess ups happen.
We try to avoid them, we
try to eliminate them.
I'm sure you guys messed up a
couple times in your business
and you go through, you
battle on, you fix them
for the next time and hope
that they don't happen again,
and I'd love to hear what mess up
you had recently in your business.
Leave that down in the comments below.
Make me feel good for our team messing up
and disappointing you guys.
I think most of all, it's
just a disappointment.
You know, we try to make content
that is high quality
that I'm really proud of.
There's a lot of work
that my entire team puts
into creating the videos
that we make every week
for you guys to help you stay motivated
and get ideas and it's
really a lot of love.
Everybody, I promise you,
everybody on the team
puts a ton of love into making sure
that it's a good quality product
as best as we know how to
make and sometimes we mess up
and this was a pretty big
mess up, and I'm really,
I'm really sorry to do that to you guys.
I'm way harder on myself, trust me,
than the comments that you
guys had for me coming in.
And thank you too for the support.
There's been some really
supportive comments,
so thank you for the love.
I really appreciate it, and again,
hopefully you can bear with us
until we get to the next
group of recordings,
but in the meantime
that you need to enjoy,
use it as an opportunity to remember
the good quality content and be grateful
for what is coming ahead, awesome
stuff next time I promise.
Thank you guys again for
the support and I'm sorry.
Hope you have a great weekend.
Continue to believe in
whatever your one word is.
Much love, guys.
I'll see you soon.